معنا من الخليل الدكتور بلال الشوبكي رئيس
قسم العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الخليل
دكتور بلال اهلا بك مستوى جديد لافت في
التعامل ورد الفعل من قبل نتنياهو وحكومته
بخصوص هذه المظاهرات ايضا لاهالي
المحتجزين ما الذي يعنيه
ذلك صباح الخير حقيقه يعني التطور في
المستوى لافت الى درجه كبيره اذا انه يعني
تجاوز مساله التلاعب في الالفاظ التي كانت
يعني يعتمدها بنيمين نتنياهو لمحاوله
احتواء الشارع الاسرائيلي ان كنتم تذكرون
في اكثر من خطاب كان يقول انا احتضن
عائلات الاسرى انا احتضن عائلات الجنود
وما الى ذلك من عبارات حاول فيها ان يظهر
نفسه مقربا من الشارع الاسرائيلي لكن
بالامس هو خون هذا الشارع بالامس شكك في
وطنيه هذا الشارع لم يستخدم العباره
بشكلها الحرفي لكن هذا ما يفهم ضمنا حين
يقول ان مثل هذه المظاهرات تعرقل الجهود
او تساعد حركه حماس او انها لا لن تفضي
الى اي منفعه حقيقيه لدوله الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هو بذلك يحاول ان
يظهر المجتمع الاسرائيلي او شريحه من
المجتمع الاسرائيلي على انها شريحه تسعى
لتحقيق اهداف ذات صبغه خاصه مرتبطه باعاده
المحتجزين على اعتبار ان امن اسرائيل هو
الاولويه وعلى اعتبار ان الحرب ضد حركه
حماس هي الاولويه وهذا تماهي ايضا مع خطاب
سموتريتش بمعنى انه
الجميع كان يقر بانه بنيامين نتنياهو في
نهايه المطاف هو مبتز سياسيا من
قبل سموتريتش وبينك فير لكنه كان يحاول
جاهدا ان يحفظ يعني مسافه بينه وبين هذين
الرجلين من حيث طبيعه الخطاب بالامس كان
هناك تماهي مطلق وا ايضا مستوى تعامل
الامن الاسرائيلي انتقل من اداره
المظاهرات او تامين هذه المظاهرات الى
التعامل بخشونه وعنف مع المتظه ظاهرين
وهذا ربما ينقلنا الى مستوى اخر وهو خصومه
الشارع الاسرائيلي بمعنى ليست مجرد
تباينات ولا اراء نحن نتحدث عن خصومه ربما
تتطور لاحقا الى شكل اخر من اشكال
المواجهات يعني هذا العنف وصل الى حد
الاعتقالات وهنا تساؤل هل بات نتنياهو
يعتمد اسلوب الهروب الى الامام كونه وصل
الى نقطه الع عوده ام
ماذا بنيامين نتنياهو في اخر خطاباته لم
يتحدث عن الواقع كان يتحدث عن المستقبل هو
ليس لديه اي شيء الان يقدم للمجتمع
الاسرائيلي على انه فعلا انجازات لانه
مؤسسه الجيش الاسرائيلي تقدم معلومات تضر
ببنيامين نتنياهو تضر بالمستوى السياسي
حين يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي من خلال هيئه
الاركان ان المناطق التي خرجوا منها باتت
الان يتم اعاده ترميم قدرات حماس المدنيه
فيها وهناك اكثر من تقرير على مدار
الاسبوعين الماضيين نحن نشهد معلومات ان
هناك محاوله لترميم المقدرات العسكريه
والمدنيه للفصائل الفلسطينيه اذا الحاضر
ليس في مصلحه بنم نتنياهو ولذلك كل خطاب
هو ملقى على المستقبل سننتصر نحتاج الى
سته اشهر مرات العديده يقول نحتاج الى
ربما عام او لا يحدد اطارا زمنيا هذا هذا
الهروب الى الامام هو فقط لاعفاء نفسه
امام الجمهور الاسرائيلي من سؤال كبير جدا
ما الذي تحقق وهو يريد ان يجيب بالطريقه
التاليه س نحقق وسنحقق هذه مساله تعفيه من
الايجاب الان وبالاضافه الى ذلك ان كنت
تذكري بالامس تحدث بشكل واضح انه ضد
عمليات التحقيق خلال الحرب يعني هو يريد
ان ينتفع الان من حاله الحرب في تعطيل اي
عمليه رقابه اي عمليه مسائله
اي وهذا فيه احساس عميق لدى بنمي نتنياهو
انه الشخص المسؤول والمحاسب والذي يفترض
ان يتلقى علامات الاستفهام من قبل المجتمع
الاس اسرائيلي سواء عن السابع من اكتوبر
او مرحله ما بعد السابع من اكتوبر والمعضل
التي واجهها بن يمين نتنياهو انه ان تحدث
عن الحاضر قابلته الفصائل الفلسطينيه
بقطاع غزه بفيديوهات تتحدث عن الحاضر
وتكذب انجازاته من خلال المقاومه الموجوده
هناك وان تحدث عن المستقبل قابلته الفصائل
الفلسطينيه بفيديوهات تتحدث عن المستقبل
اخر تسجيل والذي اشرتم اليه يعني مرارا
على على هذه الشاشه الذي تحدث عن مستقبل
الاسرى داخل قطاع غزه قال يعني هذا حديث
عن المستقبل لانه بنيمين نتنياهو يقول ان
العمليه العسكريه ستؤدي الى اعاده المحتر
ازين والفيديو يحدث المجتمع الاسرائيلي
بصيغه المستقبل لقد تم قتل كافه المحتجزين
والاسرى لدى الفصائل الفلسطينيه هذا ايضا
يعني يعطيها بعد اخر في في التحليل ان
الفصائل الفلسطينيه تطور من خطابها حركه
حماس تطور من خطابها بناء على
الاستراتيجيات الجديده اللي التي يتبعها
بنيمين نتنياهو في اداره الراي العام
ويبدو واضح ج تفضلي هنا تحديدا
استراتيجيات التي يتبعها نتنياهو هل هي
تكتيكات ناجعه بنظرك مع كل هذه المعطيات
ام انه يقامر بكل شيء وكما يقال بالعاميه
حلاوه
الروح حتى نكون دقيقين بنيمين نتنياهو نجح
حتى هذه اللحظه في اداره يعني حاله الفوضى
الموجوده في المجتمع الاسرائيلي يعني ين
فع من حاله الفوضى ويبقي نفسه في المساحه
الرماديه مساحه اللا قرار وقد نجح لمده
اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر في ان يبقى على راس
هذه الحكومه بالرغم من حاله الانتعاش على
المستوى الداخلي وبالرغم من حاله
الانتعاش الاسرائيلي من مستوى التعاطف مع
ذوي المحتجزين الى مستوى السياساتي ضاغط
من اجل اقاله الحكومه الاسرائيليه ثانيا
بدء ظه وظهور شخصيات قياديه في اسرائيل
تتبنى نبض الشارع وان كانت الان هذه
الشخصيات لا تحضى بتلك الشعبيه الا انه
امكانيه يعني تحرك ايزنكوت وبيني جانس من
من داخل مجلس الحرب الى خارج مجلس الحرب
في مرحله لاحقه قد تؤدي الى تكتل الشارع
الاسرائيلي بطريقه اكبر عدم قدره بنيامين
نتنياهو على استخدام خطاب احتوائي للشارع
الاسرائيلي اكثر من من هذه المده والدليل
على ذلك انه اصطدم بالامس بعائلات ذوي
الاسرى والمحتجزين بالاضافه الى هذا
الموضوع ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
غير معنيه بالوصول الى مرحله الفرز
الانتخابي داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والحرب مشتعله لانه كان يعول
بايدن بشكل واضح على انه يحتاج الى مسافه
ما بين الانتخابات وما بين انتهاء الحرب
حتى يتسنى له ترميم الاضرار التي حدثت في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا لك
من الخليل الدكتور بلال الشبكي رئيس قسم
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الخليل